right good afternoon everyone welcome to
this meeting of cabinets apologies for
absence and non-disclosures of interest
any disclosure to interest I'll take
that as no minutes is everyone happy
with the minutes good agreed
in that case moving on to community
portfolio notice of motion close the
door campaign councillor Hopkins that
Nigel Rock sent out because Nigel Rock
sent out numerous and I thank him for
that
a particularly interesting read before
Christmas thank you
the motion is to ask the retailers in
Stratford District Council to close
their doors and we don't need to go into
the why why that would make sense in the
climate that we're in and he's just
asked us to consider that motion does
anybody have any questions relating to
that Harvey the council will be prepared
to consider mine minions
I wonder if at this stage it might be
private to have counselor ah can join us
to answer any questions that we might
have I think that will be appropriate we
would not like to close the door -
counselor rocks intervention yes you've
got three options as how you wish to
deal with it as a fabulous day you can
either consider the motion at this
meeting which i think is what we're
doing you can ask us to report back to a
future meeting of the cabinet or you can
ask us to refer the matter to the OSC
for consideration I just wanted to check
that you are comfortable to select
section a which is consider the content
correct Thank You chairman obviously I'd
be interested in listening to any
questions suggestions or ideas that
might you know endorse the spirit of
what was it out as councillor Hajis
hugging just said I'll put some notes
around to try and embroider it
particularly noting it was going to be
considered at council I've got a few
more bits and pieces of information you
know more number of councils that have
worked on this in the past ones with
your Westminster Chelsea and Westminster
Camden Islington City London Boris
Johnson when he was mayor of London
endorsed each campaign as well as the
other things that are put in there about
if you're on on a Main Street the
pollution as well as the environmental
benefits one of the other benefits or
two or three that have benefits
reduction in shoplifting and also
something I hadn't thought of is the
risk to children running out of the shop
has also been reduced so that's some of
the findings that have been found out in
my conversations with the team that have
been promoting this so well
I'll stop there because I think you know
I'd be interesting the questions or any
other suggestions that came forward but
it's not terribly major in your foot I'm
lying you use the word or should I
wonder whether you would consider
changing that to be encouraged because
there may be circumstances in which the
retailer has a good reason for doing
what he does whereas to encourage them
to Rock absolutely agree that fine with
me fine my secondary sitting behind me
I'm sure yes right so the options open
to us are a consider the content to the
motion can I just make an observation
there are there are numerous times that
motions are brought to us as a cabinet
and I have to say this is one of those
where is the the idea and the thought
and why is trying to be achieved is
universally accepted and it's really
encouraging to see members bring things
forward so I think councillors Rock and
Curtis should be congratulated for
bringing this forward to us as a motion
so that we can then through our
processes start to give life to some of
these changes I think it's an example of
a really positive motion brought forward
by by members of the authority and I
think is to be applauded for that
looking at the recommendation on page 11
and option a consider the content to the
motion of the meeting and we are
supportive of the notice of motion is
cabinet agreed Thank You members of
cabinet German can I just say thank you
for your kind words and consideration
for the motion thank you to problem
councillor rock climate emergency
councillor Richards I believe you want
to introduce this final report of the
climate emergency task and finish group
if I make sure that's very kind members
as you know I'm chair of the overview
and scrutiny committee we do have the
chair of the task finish group with us
as well counts they're juniors I'm sure
she'll have something to say once I'm
done but I will start by introducing and
giving a little bit background as well
so last year we set the ambitious target
for the district's become carbon neutral
by 2030 over the plan the last few
months we've heard a lot about this
ambition but saying we just simply
saying that we want to be ambitious or
we want to be more ambitious is not
going to be enough what the toxin finish
group has done is to actually flesh out
these ambitions and design a workable
and realistic approach to achieving them
the group has done this quite following
suggested approached my deputy leader
which was specifically to make headline
recommendations to inform future work
and that work will be overseen by the
Standing panels approved to them and
previous meeting in the cabinet this has
been as I'm sure you can understand a
very challenging task given the scale of
of it and it is essentially
unprecedented in modern times in four
months which I'm sure you all understand
is an extraordinarily tight timescale
for such an issue the group has had a
lot of evidence from mems of the public
from various bodies some of whom are
here
this today and produced the report
that's in front of view along with the
Associated action plan as well as making
interim recommendations in October and
November last year the final report
brings together this but so it brings
this together and provides a background
to the issue outlines technical
challenges and summarizes the work of
the group a few points worth noting from
that report the group was asked to
assess the current work of the council
we found there was no overarching
climate change strategy in place climate
change did in the feature specifically
in the 2015 19 so it did not feature in
the 2015 19 corporate strategy and
there's been no dedicated officer post
in place and there's no explicit public
communications or engagement strategy in
place whilst there is evidence of strong
legacy work the task and finish group
was essentially having to start anew on
an approach to climate change was also
considering whether the district-wide
target of 2030 was realistic the report
concluded that is not yet clear whether
district-wide ambition is in fact an
achievable goal especially with national
policy working towards 2050 and has a
carbon neutral target however we can get
our own house in order and the
district-wide target is one that should
be pursued in good faith the ignoring
climate change in its impact is quite
simply not a viable option the report
sets out how we should move forward with
a roadmap to 2030 based on the action
plan if approved endorsed by his cabinet
by this time next year we we will be
sitting here with a following in place a
new council carbon reduction plan up and
running for our own estate and operating
with public monitoring of this through
new KPIs a new communications campaign
up and running to boost recycling and
reuse waste a taxi license licensing
policy in place to make sure all taxis
are either electric zero or ultra low
emissions and a significant increase in
evey charging points across the district
a new Community Health established to
engage with residents a far-reaching
district-wide home insulation policy
ready to launch a bulk by scheme in
place for residents to access solar
panels or other technologies a major
district-wide tree planting campaign
bearing
to speak having been launched in the
autumn we will identify the land and be
establishing in community projects to
promote biodiversity community
allotments and education opportunities
we will ever move to paperless committee
meetings have an investment strategy
that underpins our climate change
ambitions have an adaption strategy that
aligns with our emerging core strategy
well we will also be holding regular
climate forums to engage with local
partners businesses as well as having
established a Citizens panel to engage
with residents and over 2020 we all have
been working with regional partners on
issues such as transport the single
biggest barrier to achieving carbon
neutral district and we would have
established a genuine track record of
lobbying government on a range of issues
including finance infrastructure and
planning policy personally I think that
work program overseen by the Standing
panel will be a challenging it will be a
challenge for both officers and members
alike if the council achieves it then I
think we would have got a long way to
showing residents that we are taking
this issue very seriously and will have
moved from a well-meaning platitudes
about ambition to detailed action I
therefore wholeheartedly recommend this
to the cabinet and ask that you endorsed
the report and action plan
thank you very much thank you leader so
I had the benefit of sitting in on a
number of the meetings of the task and
finish group to see some of the work
first hand and I would say that this is
a report to be welcomed and I would say
for the benefit of sort of people in the
audience and and for members of the
press I think that we as an organization
have already taken steps beyond
platitudes the task and finish group was
persuasive in an argument to move in the
short term to
bolstering our core strategy policies by
the design and I thank our officers for
it and implementation of what's called a
supplementary planning document which is
a mechanism by which we can provide
additional support to our existing core
strategy policies and our core strategy
our development plan is a vital tool in
achieving our climate change objectives
because of its impact on the built
environment and I think that the that
commit the the task and finish group was
persuasive in us moving to put that
document in place early and there was
the debate about that and I think that
that should be seen as a statement of
intent that this council intends to take
action rather than just produce a report
and let it gather dust and for not there
to be substantive change so that's
already a huge tick in the box for this
group and set sets the direction of
travel in welcoming the the report my
view is that so we were we've had these
papers we've had some interim
recommendations and now we've got the
final set of recommendations and it
behooves us as a cabinet and as a
management team and as an organization
to give this thing proper and due
consideration and perhaps to manage the
expectations of the members of the press
across the way there we're not going to
be able to do that this afternoon and I
think it would be my view that as a
cabinet we need to take this and just
look at it in detail understand the
action plan start to give some thoughts
around everything that sits alongside
the action plan and how we
operationalize this if you will in the
short term and to come back with a set
of views that we can then feed into the
structure that we know we all need to
set up that's going to work on an
ongoing basis where members across this
council help to drive and shape our
climate change
policies and how that then fits a long
thin things like our transformation
strategy you know how do we achieve
paperless the transformation plan
already works towards that so I think
what we need to do is to be able to take
the document away and my recommendation
is that we are going to take the
document away and take some time to
consider it in detail take further
soundings I know that justin has a
meeting with the county and other and
other local authorities in the next
couple weeks understand where they're at
so that we can then start to build and
give life and actually move the thing
forward so my view would be that we take
this and that we set ourselves aside
some time to consider it in detail and
to come back to a future cabinet meeting
even reasonably short order probably the
one after next is my initial thought
process to be in a position where we can
react properly and in detail to this
really detailed piece of work and how we
actually then move it forward and how we
help set the priorities and that would
be my viewers to be in terms of the way
forward but I would just want to finally
thank the members of the group for
delivering on a piece of work and that
it's already made some some impact Thank
You councillor Pemberton I would just
say I would agree I welcome the report I
think what's already been said by
councillor Richards there are an awful
lot of massive and complex issues in
here
climate change is probably one of the
biggest issues we face I agree with
councilor Pemberton we need to consider
it and we need to consider it very
carefully because this is not something
to do half-cocked we will come back to
cabinet I would tend to agree with
councillor Pemberton given the
complexity of it it may well be the
cabinet after next we will not have a
considerin even thought we have to
accept it is complex it is difficult I
would say that we have made a commitment
to fund our climate change projects to
the tune of five hundred thousand which
is in the budget so it's not as though
we lack commitment
so with that cabinet are we happy to
take this away councillor jonad some of
the things you've already have already
been before previous cabinets and you've
already agreed the SPD and it's already
gone to strategy and you have agreed
actually the carbon management plan and
and that is one of the most important
parts of this because we you need to get
together the data that the targets and
and then also develop ways to engage
stakeholders and carry people with you I
would not actually ask you to delay too
long because I think you'd say the most
important bit is that carbon management
plan which you've already agreed to
something work is and should be getting
on with that mandatory target we're
reporting on greenhouse gas was
unfortunately withdrawn by government
but it needs to you if you can't measure
it you can't put targets and you can't
move forward and then there actually
does need to be an annual budget for
karma carbon performers just as there is
for financial budgets every single year
this is a start of a journey I would not
want you to hesitate and delay too long
you've got to we you need that task
force of officers leading it you need a
standing panel and I think you've
already agreed to that and and then we
you need to start getting on with their
work through this next year to make sure
that you know we've already got through
the they an agreed by this cabinet that
procurement for example this should be
10% evaluation on any any any contract
that they should be a climate change
action plan
they're the most important bit is to get
that budget once you've got that budget
you can you can set against almost
everything that you want to do can be
set against that budget what would know
that that budget is in place and it's
agreed so I would I would say don't
delay really toward to be honest you
know let's start moving forward on it
and start the stunning panel starting to
think seriously about how we move to the
next stage
I think councils unit we've said we will
come back as quickly as we can and
probably the cabinet after next council
Richard I think you see things that
might help with your the way things move
forward clearly it's within your gift is
cabinet we're making a recommendation
you are the decision body you can decide
how you want to progress and the
principle of a standing panel has been
set it was originally as no se Standing
panel if you again it's within your gift
to decide who sits on that it could be
wider and have either yourself or deputy
or any other member of the cabinet on
that to ensure that the work does
dovetail with your ambitions also in
terms of speed what I realize you're not
trying to delay for the sake of delay
there is clearly an ambition of this
this council to progress with on the
climate emergency and climate change
issue we as a council want to be a
leader in all things while we sit here
today as far as I'm aware with the only
council and local authority within
Warwickshire that has brought this topic
this far
we're the only ones that have produced a
final report I wouldn't want to lose
that opportunity where we can be that
leadership group and progress this
properly I'm sure that's well on your
radar but I just want to raise that
point I think those two should help I
understand councillor Richards and I
think this is why we actually need to
consider things very carefully because
we need the right people on the right
groups in the right place
so with that cabinet are you happy that
we take this away actually explore it
and come back at the latest of the
cabinet in March
Thank You members of cabinet so moving
on revenue and capital budget twenty
twenty one to twenty four twenty five
councillor Harvey I believe you're
introducing this Thank You leader
the purpose of this report is to present
the draft revenue and capital budgets to
the cabinet for approval for the basis
upon which both the public and the
overview and scrutiny committee can be
consulted the intention is that the
outcome of these consultations will be
considered by the Cabinet and its
meeting on the 10th of February before
the final proposals are put before the
council at its meeting on the 24th of
February in order to come to a view on
the shape of the proposals set out in
the deployment there's a need to take a
view on what position that canal the
council's finances are in one
interpretation is that there's little
need for change as later papers indicate
the council is projected to generate an
excess of income over expenditure in the
current financial year of approaching
300,000 pounds it will generate a new
Holmes bonus payment of 5.3 million
pounds more than it has before and the
level of its general fund reserves is
projected to be nine point three million
pounds at the end of the year on this
interpretation the patient is in good
health and there's no need for any
different treatment but we know that the
future will not be the same as the past
whilst we've had the benefit this year
in the unexpected rollover of the
existing local government funding regime
for another year we know that this will
not continue the government has made
local authorities aware of two
significant changes that will impact on
future years first we know there's every
intention to announce later this year a
new four-year settlement for the period
20 21 22 onwards there have been strong
indications that there will be an end to
the new homes boats as part of that
settlement second the government has
announced where it intends to allocate
for local authorities additional funds
for local authorities all the
indications are that District Council's
will not be amongst those to benefit the
structural changes that have impacted on
the cap on the council's finances in
recent years are set to continue and to
accelerate the annual amount received in
the revenue support grant the rural
services delivery grant and the
transition grant was 3.8 million pounds
seven years ago next year these sources
will provide nothing next year this
council is likely to receive new homes
bonus of 5.3 million pounds and over the
next three years it will be half and
half again until it is reduced to
nothing this council can look forward
therefore to losing income from this
source over the next three years of 9.5
million pounds it needs to be borne in
mind but assuming of the five pound is
added to AB and D Council taxpayer for
the coming year and if an increase of 2
percent were applied for the following
two years the council would generate
nearly six hundred thousand pounds to
compensate for this loss of nine point
five million pounds over the period the
reserve strategy set out in appendix
seven of the paper demonstrate that
there's a reasonable expectation that
over the next five years
the council's general fund reserve could
be reduced from nine point three million
pounds to three million pounds the
proposals before you have been prepared
against the uncertainty of what will
come out of the next four years
settlement but as far as district
councils in general and this council in
particular are concerned the direction
of travel
the sign person it's on this basis that
the proposals set out in the report are
presented we want to ensure as far as
possible this council is in a position
to provide as many services for its
residents into the future as it does
today
these proposals were based on a
realistic and responsible recognition of
the way the world is and as it is most
likely to be not on the way we would
simply wish it to be I'll conclude by
confirming that all those people these
proposals while the result of much
thought and discussion between the
council's offices and portfolio holders
they are presented as the basis for
genuine consultation and to demonstrate
that members of the cabinet are opened
to comment and counter suggestions about
what is proposed I can confirm that
although the increase in the proper
permits for over 65s has been included
in page on page 41 based upon an
increase of 50 pounds the consultation
will proceed on the basis that this
proposed increase will be 25 pounds so
two questions that I am more likely to
section 1 5 1 officer answer I'd like
members of the cabinet endorse and
recommend for scrutiny the
recommendations 1 to 7 set out on page
13 and the respected and appendices to
which 33rd thank you leader Thank You
councillor Harvey councillor sorry
having members of cabinet any comments
or observations councillor jonad and I
was just looking through some of the sit
for comments recently and some articles
that were in the Municipal Journal this
week as well Ferrer's actually said that
the vast majority of local authorities
are showing no signs of major financial
stress the circuit circled 10% of them
show some signs of potential risk to
their financial stability and that was a
for quote this week and the municipal
journal is saying that revenue support
would be top sized to continue the new
homes bonus scheme and that 150 2.9
million will be given by government to
eliminate any negative revenue support
grant it's not a different message that
they admit their miserable Journal is
reporting and set for reporting than the
newest officers Aras and Anna's Council
but folio holders are obviously receive
nothing certainly the issue for
Stratford District Council is in the
short term they are showing no financial
stress if one looks ahead for years
we're showing very considerable
financial stress so I think it depends
on the perspective one is looking at I
have to say that all the indications
I've had from all the consultations I've
heard about is the trend is in one
direction for us and that is not good
mr. Buckland would you wish to comment
on that are you making representations
to government accordingly we already
have and we will be making more just
comment on the position in relation to
the negative revenues for Graham because
it was something that was certainly no
local authorities what those authorities
who would come as we have reduction in
revenues program potentially we were
looking at negative revenue support come
in 2000 19 20 and 20 to 21 the
government hadn't previously indicated
that they wouldn't do negative when you
spoke on some that isn't an issue that
has affected us and doesn't appear
within the medium term financial plan
Chancellor Pemberton thank you later I'm
really sorry but I just make the
observation that are you asking us to
produce a budget based on the numbers in
front of us or on a report in the in
professional journals really sorry guys
but let's let's just get real here we
have to produce a budget based on the
numbers in front of us there's all sorts
of stuff in all sorts of journals
newspapers that tell you the world is
one way you don't base your financial
decisions on them
and I'm sorry you know we dude with all
due deference to cancel Richards
financial but the reality is yes of
course we lobby for more money and yes
we do take account of it but we can't
just turn around and say well it's in
the journal therefore I'm sorry I'm
absolutely we've all seen these numbers
and I'm afraid there isn't an easy get
out clause for anybody here all right in
that case then can I go back onto your
own counsel figures looking at the
actual forecast an actual since 2012 13
13 14 14 15 15 16 etc right up till
today in every single one of those years
your actual has ended up more than your
forecast so in every single one of those
years the councillors ended up better
off as a result over the your original
forecast and then then every single one
of those years the council has ended up
with more money in this pocket than than
they originally forecast at this stage
of the game yes we we have benefited in
the past particularly from planning
income that as by far exceeded our
expectations and now has contributed
significantly to those surpluses and but
what we try to do this year is can is
tighten the budget up both in terms of
income projections and expenditure
projections so where were determined to
get them a budget that we hit on target
this year and don't under or overspend
any further comments I think I would
just particularly around this question
of you know under spending the section
one five one officer has done a huge
amount of work around areas where
historically we have we have had under
spends and each and every one of the
portfolio holders and each and every one
of the heads of service were tasked with
looking at their budgets looking at
their establishment looking at income
and actually to take a far more
realistic and approach and one that
borne reality I will give you a for
example over a number of years there
have been various elements where we have
received particular grants year in year
out and historically our practice has
not been to account for those and that
then creates a position where you have
income ahead of what you're anticipating
we have changed that approach so that
those sources of income for example that
we know are in there and there's one
particularly around the police grant
wasn't it
sixty thousand pounds it's those kind of
things that the budget has tightened up
on so this represents the reality of
where we're at none of us want to be in
a position where we increase the burden
on our residents more than is necessary
to deliver the services that our
residents want us to deliver and to
deliver the change that our residents
want us to deliver so to suggest that
there is a magic formula that says we
don't have to do this or we can defer
there no I've not seen anything that
suggests the numbers would bear that out
and I would wholeheartedly support the
section one five one officer and the
portfolio holder and bringing these
numbers forward and they should we
should take them out for consultation
thank you you wish to speak
well firstly I'd like to have counselors
Shenton for having a couple of
conversations with me about the over 65s
car parking permit and listening to what
I had to say and the emails I have as
you might well imagine received many
many emails and phone calls from
residents who simply would not pay 50
pounds and one of them was actually my
husband who has said that he'll Drive
around the streets it's not good for
climate change he'll drive around the
streets to find free parking so that is
this is very good it's good news
but is this a smokescreen can you answer
me honestly next year you're going to
put it up again the following year are
you going to put it up again or is this
going to be a one-off cost for the next
three years thank you I can answer that
very very honestly that there has been
no decision on that it would be wrong to
say that we wouldn't review and look at
all costs that goes across the board
there has been no decision to increase
it it's 25 pounds
and we'll look at it again next year if
inflation is running rampant you might
might consider inflation rise I don't
know I may not even be in the position
this time next year I can't tie the
hands of olive equal time there is you
know there's no suggestion of increasing
okay
may I just have a follow-up so you are
going to out to consultation now on 25
pounds if in the responses that you
receive people are still unhappy with
that will you take that into account or
are you gonna stretch 25 pence and I
think that one oh can we be absolutely
clear that consultation is exactly what
it says it's consultation people do not
have a veto on decisions
counselor should I think you just said
what I was gonna say this is a
consultation a consultation we can't
make decisions for ritalin and that's a
requirement it's laid out within the
budget papers thank you and with that
our contribution counselor riches can I
say that looking at the recommendations
on page 13 our cabinet happy with those
recommendations thank you members of
cabinet so moving on to the brownfield
Land Register part one Chancellor
Pemberton thank you thank you leader to
draw members attention to page 127 of
the cabinet papers so this is the
brand-- field register which covers
brownfield sites to be developed or are
a work in progress so this this is
innocent in some respects a current and
retrospective list of the register that
we have helps us understand the
opportunities for development on
brownfield and it's a requirement that
the register be published on an annual
basis members can see at Appendix 1 the
brownfield register the worst some
updates to the register previously
brought forward to make to provide
clarity in terms of the location the
original register looked at to the
original application Ward's and of
course a number of those application
sites as now sit in different wards
because of the the changes towards a
couple of years ago remember it's just
asked that the the register part won't
be endorsed for publication on the on
the website Thank You councillor
Pemberton any questions or comments
members of cabinet are we happy with the
recommendation on page 127 agreed Thank
You members of cabinet so moving on
capital budget monitoring
councillor Harvey Thank You folks of
this Baker's to keep members informed
the progress made over the first eight
months of the year and undertaking the
council's intended level of capital
expenditures is here table 1 on page 1 4
1 demonstrates the intention to unfix
expector of 6.35 winning fans this year
including section 106 projects taking
into account additional funds of the
three leading pounds budgeted for this
year this will result in the balance of
councils accumulated capital receipts
and grants being reduced over the year
from fight went cycling pounds to 2.3
million pounds paragraph 1 5 indicates
the capital expenditure of 1 million
pounds has been committed and 492
thousand pounds has already been
undertaken by the end of November
totally committed and undertaken
expenditure in the first eight months of
the year that is 1 million the 540
thousand pounds represents twenty four
point six percent of this year's
available budget appendix 2 on page one
five one provides summary information
concerning the various projects yet to
be funded through section 106 agreements
I'd like to draw attention to a single
element that is the degree to which the
amounts of mad funds allocated under
section 106 agreements that relate to
affordable housing at present 2.6
million of the 3.5 million value of
section 106 agreements in other words
nearly three-quarters of public event
available is earmarked in relation to
the provision of affordable housing the
current position on catholics been
thank you 90,000 pounds
this represents two and a half percent
two and a half percent of net cost of
the services provided period this is the
result of the receipt of some seven
hundred thousand pounds of both budget
during the first eight months this has
been offset by a combination of over
budgeted expenditures of 16,000 pounds
on the one hand and the difference
between the budgeted and actual cost
dealing with benefits the difference of
311 fair amount
members will see from the final figure
in the bottom right hand corner of the
preceding page that's on think
quantities
pink exceeding its expenditure by an
estimated three hundred seventy nine
thousand pounds given the pressures of
the council will be facing in the coming
years
as we discussed earlier this is to be
welcomed any questions members may have
a half the information in this report is
noted any questions or comments if not
are we happy with the recommendation on
page one five nine members of cabinet
Thank You members of cabinet moving on
to the studly leisure center extension
project Chancellor Whaley Huggins
any questions or comments members of
cabinet in that case and we're happy
with the recommendations that councillor
Huggins has outlined Anna which are on
page 171 you can thank you so we have no
issues arising from overview and
scrutiny apart from the matter already
considered nothing from cabinet
committees from bloc items member
development working group and to receive
the minutes so we counselor Carl want
very brief on on the member development
in the climate change but the appendix
there they mentioned about training and
that's obviously going to go to run
through member development and be very
clean to have that people come back to
me with any ideas on on what training we
need Thank You counselor cardio so with
that we've received the minutes of the
member development working group
there's no urgent business I live hell
declare this meeting of cabinet